[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm mark austin with
a sky news special program
as the last u.s and uk troops head home
from
afghanistan coming up the taliban on the
march as coalition forces leave an
exclusive report with the militants
trying to take control this is a crucial
highway which the taliban have been
trying to get control of
but the fact that the taliban have got
so close to
the capital showing them making gains
we're also with the national army and
the militias now trying to stop
history repeating itself with very
little
western help they're gonna fight for
democracies we speak today
they're gonna fight for the rights of
the people they're gonna fight for the
rights of the
uh woman the ultimate sacrifice the
british troops who gave their lives
fighting a 20-year war
and the big question was it really worth
it
also the ministry of defense works to
prevent withdrawal becoming a disaster
and a former mi6
chief says the west could be making a
terrible mistake
also the future for women fighting to
hold on to their basic rights to go to
school
to get a job and to live their lives
good evening it wasn't meant to be like
this after two decades of conflict
costing trillions of pounds and
thousands of deaths
nato forces are slipping quietly out of
afghanistan
no fanfare no ceremony and certainly no
great claims
of mission accomplished there have been
achievements
al-qaeda has been largely defeated three
million girls are back in education
and the national army in afghanistan is
better equipped
and trained but and here's the thing the
taliban
is resurgent taking new territory with
every passing week
and it is threatening to return to power
with its harsh brand of islamic justice
repression of women and girls
and its recent history of harboring
terrorists
in this special program i'll be speaking
to the taliban leadership
we look at the risks ahead and we also
look back at the awful
cost in lives afghan lives of course but
also many british
and american ones and we hear from a top
british general who led forces in
afghanistan
about what has been achieved and where
and why the west has failed but first
this evening our special correspondent
alex crawford has been with the taliban
as they make their advance across the
country here is her
exclusive report the taliban are on the
march
and gaining territory at an astonishing
rate
we've been invited to meet them inside
their own base they want to show us
as foreign journalists how strong they
are and also how they're in no mood to
compromise
the departure of the bulk of the
american and other nato forces has
emboldened them and they smell
victory one commander in warduk province
told me they would never work alongside
the other groups in government
as a real afghan we would never do that
because they are the people who are
killing and kidnapping
who are thieves and who are corrupt so
we'll never work with them
we're the first foreign journalists to
see the latest army base the taliban
have captured in the province
and they want to show us the treasure
trove of military riches they've seized
with it
many of these boxes supplied by the
americans hadn't even been opened before
the taliban got hold of them
can anyone believe that the taliban
wants peace when you've
you've got all these weapons now
most of the time we don't rely on all of
this we just rely on allah
but it does help us a lot and it's given
us a lot of new weapons we can use in
battle
of course we want peace more people want
peace here but the government doesn't
want peace with us
from this base alone the taliban say
they seized about 900
guns 30 humvees and 20 army pickup
trucks
it's a whole pile of of destroyed
vehicles military vehicles there and a
huge
area that they've managed to take over
i think this the taliban will see this
and view this as a substantial victory
and it follows a nationwide pattern of
afghan soldiers putting up
only a half-hearted fight many of the
fighters we saw were carrying new
weapons
seized during the taking of the base
the white flag that signifies the
taliban takeover is flying in large
swathes of the country right now
and they're creeping closer to the
capital
our journey on route to the taliban was
halted this is a crucial
highway which the taliban have been
trying to get control of
the afghan army brought in
reinforcements to push them back
but the fact that the taliban have got
so close to
the capital
making gains
the taliban are winning the propaganda
war able to plant and
detonate roadside bombs with few
reassurances from the government about
how they're going to regain control
instead in taliban controlled areas they
blame the afghan national army for
injuries and insecurity
we saw no women at all out in public
although the taliban insists they've
progressed
and want their girls educated do you all
welcome the taliban being here
[Music]
the taliban paint themselves as deeply
religious
and say they're fighting for an islamic
emirate based on a strict interpretation
of sharia law
like so many others this former prisoner
jailed by the americans immediately
rejoined the fight on his release
the only thing that will persuade me to
put down my gun is if there's islamic
law here
based entirely on islam and the
government is run according to islamic
rules
the taliban resurgence appears to have
real momentum and that's worrying for
the afghan government and its
international allies
who are now watching all the military
hardware they handed over
ending up in the hands of the group
they're meant to be used against
the government is seen as weak and
deeply unpopular in areas
particularly where the taliban have
managed to take a hold
can you work with any of them they are
nothing anything
you're nothing and this we will destroy
three
we are we are going to
destroy our country they
they come they bring bad
situation for afghanistan for our people
for our civilized for our country
for our schools for our
hospitals everything they destroyed
and this while peace talks are meant to
be ongoing and all the while the taliban
seem to be growing
stronger and that will surely lessen
their desire to do
any deals
and alex joins us live now from kabul
good evening
alex and uh afghanistan traditionally is
full of militias run by
warlords are they also taking up the
fight against the taliban
well certainly there's a great deal of
worry amongst ordinary afghan civilians
about who is going to take on the
taliban now that the international
troops
have left the country or all but left
the country
they're hearing every day about the
afghan national army seeding territory
of the taliban sometimes giving up their
bases and moving out
without even a fight or a half-hearted
fight the taliban
are taking part in peace negotiations
but they are clearly
extremely confident right now and they
are playing a very
very strong hand i heard from a senior
taliban source who wouldn't be named
that they are hoping to retake
their birthplace of kandahar by eid
which is july 19th they're talking about
coming up with their
own peace plan probably possibly as
early as next week
and that could involve them taking
control of certain parts of the country
the obvious option is the south
their stronghold now that is
deeply concerning and very very worrying
for all those civilians who do not want
to see
the return to the taliban regime who do
not want them
to see them taking any control
whatsoever
and they've been calls for a national
mobilization
of these armed militia to take on the
taliban
the afghan army is now all that stands
between every town
and the taliban the soldiers who've
relied so much on
international training air support and
weaponry are now being left to tackle
the taliban insurgency on their
own every time that they leave their
barracks they know that they are the
focus of any attacks by the taliban
because the taliban want to show
that they're coming back into power and
it's only a matter of time before they
take
over the taliban's already moved into
dozens of districts across the country
and they're circling the capital
roadblocks are set up to try to secure
the perimeter
but the weapons on the streets indicate
just how insecure afghanis are about
their own
safety the uncertainty is palpable
and there's a great deal of tension
everywhere
the afghan soldiers fear they're now
fighting al-qaeda
and isis thought to already be embedded
within the taliban
and the scramble by international troops
to get out of afghanistan
appears to have empowered their enemies
who've had some rapid successes on the
ground
there's an awful lot of land that they
have got to try and get back
from the taliban and without those
international troops
they have got their work cut out for
them but the civilians are growing more
nervous
with reports of soldiers surrendering
and bases routed
but every soldier we spoke to is putting
up a brave front
the taliban tried to disrupt by laying
mines he told us
but we use our technical teams to find
them before they explode
but that confidence and the ability to
take on the taliban
isn't matched elsewhere
the rocky terrain of northern
afghanistan is home to the country's
most formidable fighting partnership
different fighters known as mujahideen
who joined forces
to form the northern alliance the relics
remain in the pangshi valley
of how they beat back superpowers like
the soviet union
and kept the taliban at bay
the son of the man who led them to those
victories is now stepping up to stop
this new taliban takeover
we were given rare access as his convoy
of
suvs and armoured vehicles crisscrossed
the region
often at high speed
there's a feeling there's no time to
lose with the taliban trouncing
areas in the north but the security
force with him
is devoted to him and his cause
if talib will not accept the peace
we will fight with them okay you're
ready for this
yeah absolutely
hundred percent masood was only 12 when
his father was assassinated
two days before 9 11.
the young man educated in london has
enormous support here
when he talks they listen and the crowds
in his home region are looking to him
to lead them in the new fight against
extremism
the young masood insists the national
army needs help
and without international troop support
the mujahideen are the only fighters who
can give it
he says there are thousands like these
men armed and ready to beat back the
taliban and their extremist allies
they're gonna fight for democracies we
speak today they're gonna fight for the
rights of the people
they're gonna fight for the rights of
the uh woman and they're going to fight
for many other
values that we cherished and we love and
we achieved in the past two or three
decades so
these are the things that they're ready
to defend the preparations for battle
come amid predictions that the afghan
government's heading for a swift
collapse
prompting a fresh migration crisis and
increased
isis attacks we are the first line of
defense we are defending europe we are
defending the region
and afghans are fighting not just for
themselves but for everyone
but former president karzai urged
afghans to all lay down their guns
and saved his strongest criticism for
america
the west must explain to us the presence
of daesh in afghanistan
it emerged during
the u.s prisons in afghanistan in the
name of fight
against extremism and terrorism
so they have failed america may dream
this is the end of its longest war
but those arming themselves now ready
for more battles
fear it is far from done
let's go back to uh alex crawford in
kabul and alex there are reports tonight
that the taliban is saying they'll
present a peace proposal maybe by
next month i mean could there be a sort
of multi-party
negotiated settlement
i mean clearly that's the hope everyone
wants some sort of settlement and some
sort of
agreement certainly i think based on the
taliban fighters that i saw
in wardak province they are in no mood
to compromise
they can't see themselves sharing
government or sharing power with any of
these groups particularly let's take for
a start ashraf ghani's
government at the moment who they
perceive as weak and corrupt
and part of the problem they definitely
do not
feel that they can offer out a hand of
friendship to other
warlords and other militia groups so
that's
not likely to happen either so very
difficult to see
what the future holds and certainly if
you look at u.s intelligence reports for
instance they're predicting
a collapse of the current government
possibly within months maybe sooner than
that maybe within
weeks so the future does not look very
rosy at all for afghanistan however
there are
a lot of factors at play which they will
use
as a as a carrot and stick to try and
make
all these groups come together former
president
karzai for one is is is one of those
people who are spearheading trying to
get these groups to come together trying
to persuade everyone
that it is in no one's interest
definitely not afghanistan's
for afghans to be fighting afghans
but he is furious about the emergence of
isis
here in this country and you heard from
ahmed masudan
and others we've spoken to warning about
the dire consequences not just to the
region but to the world
about what is likely to happen with this
power vacuum
and how it is in the international
community's uh best interest to try and
really put all their efforts into trying
trying to resolve what's happening in
afghanistan here
before it emerges into a massive
humanitarian crisis
another migration crisis and economic
collapse
more isis attacks which won't just be
contained to this area they'll
blossom out and spread like the covert
virus all around the world
uh alex for now thanks very much we'll
be back uh with you before the end of
the
hour let's just give this some context
and look at the origins of the war and
some of the major developments over the
past
20 years uh two decades in which afghan
civilians have suffered
huge losses of life while the afghan
government keeps the army's death toll
secret
to avoid damaging morale estimates show
that between 66 and 69
000 afghan soldiers have also been
killed and the war
has now cost an approximate two and a
quarter
trillion dollars and in the aftermath of
the 9 11 attacks the bush administration
issued an ultimatum to the taliban to
give up the al-qaeda leader osama bin
laden
that was rejected leading to operation
enduring freedom which began in october
of that year
the taliban controlled the majority of
the country save an enclave
held by the northern alliance
the taliban administration had collapsed
by december hamid karzai the future
president that alex was talking about
there was sworn in
as interim leader the number of
coalition forces on the ground
relatively small then but there had
already been 12
fatalities then in may 2003 george bush
declared
an end to major combat operations in
both iraq
and afghanistan coalition forces had
grown to 18
100 and there had been 140 deaths
of coalition military personnel
then for eight years coalition forces
fought against a bloody insurgency it
was not until may
2011 that osama bin laden the ostensible
reason
uh for the war was killed by u.s forces
in pakistan coalition forces had
ballooned
in number by then to 131 300
as had the number of coalition deaths
they went up to 2837.
this marked the start of a gradual drift
of the war from uh public gays in
october 2014 british troops ended their
combat operations
coalition forces had shrunk to 44
hundred but the number killed it
continued to rise
with isis now operating in afghanistan
as well
by 2018 donald trump was president
having promised an end to what he was
calling america's forever wars
the taliban had begun to recover much of
their lost territory following a halving
of coalition forces and a stabilization
of the military deaths that reflected
more modest
ambitions on the ground in february 2020
donald trump
signed a peace deal with the taliban
without the approval of the afghan
government but the year was marked
by more violent attacks including a mass
shooting
in a maternity hospital with the
withdrawal virtually complete the
taliban are now estimated to control
or contest over three quarters of
afghan districts fewer than 10 000
coalition forces were deployed in this
end game to the conflict a conflict
that's claimed
over 75 000 civilian lives
and more than 3 500
military ones now those lives lost 455
were british military personnel at one
stage of the war it became a grim
weekly ritual to hear the prime minister
of the day read out the names of those
killed
and the quiet wiltshire town of wooden
bassette became the center of public
grief over the cost
of the war as the funeral cortege of the
dead pass through
a recent study said that british
soldiers were twice as likely to be
killed as u.s troops mainly because they
were patrolling
in highly dangerous helmand province
james matthews reports now on a snapshot
of the sacrifice
the uk armed forces have made in this
war
leaving afghanistan doesn't mean
afghanistan leaves there
soldiers who served like stuart pearson
and families who waited back home like
bob and jem
wright the parents of mark i used to say
well but if you go out
any and there's any trouble hide behind
the biggest tree
i'm in afghanistan mum there's no any
big trees
we've got a man marking stewart's
horrific story has been graphically
depicted on the big screen even
impossible due to location
being minefield with colleagues the two
friends became trapped in a minefield
after going in to help a fellow soldier
who'd stood on a mine
of four explosions the second took off
stewart's left leg
i took my foot off a rock my left foot
and put it on the ground and that's when
i
that's when i heard the explosion um i
get
blown up slightly and twisted round the
soldiers have called for a helicopter
with a winch
to lift out casualties and relative
safety but they were told none was
available
the downdraft from a landing chinook set
off another mine
unfortunately mark who was straddling
over me protecting me from the
the down blast of the helicopter he got
blasted
by that injuries to his face neck and
upper body
mark wright survived the first explosion
that caught him he was badly injured
but continued to communicate on the
radio and with critically injured
colleagues
i remember just lying here thinking i
don't know if i can hold on for another
hour here
um but mark wasn't i was wanting to fall
asleep but mark wouldn't let anyone
fall asleep he was shouting at us after
four hours us
blackhawk helicopters arrived at the
site near afghanistan's kajaki dam
and winched the casualties to safety
four mines had injured eight soldiers
mark wright was hit twice as mark was
getting
winched up by the blackhawks he then
shouted down tell jolene and my family
that i love them
every night when it was me before we
went to sleep always here i love you
i always thought i did if i'm dead in
the morning absolutely that was the last
words i heard
and i mean when he used to phone he
always says bye i love you
i thought that crashed that's over then
i looked upside my mark was
lying there and i looked again and
paramount if i rolled on top and gave
him cpr
and then i looked again at me and it was
gone
just took the breath away i just thought
that's our life over
at the inquest into mark wright's death
the coroner called him an exceptional
soldier
whose death was down to a series of
failures a lack of appropriate uk
helicopters
with a winch the downdraft from the
chinook
and the delay in sending an appropriate
helicopter
i'd say a lot of these decisions are
just made by there may be people who
sits in whitehall that have never
fought a battle at all taken one day and
fought an enemy so
um quite you know quite a quite
disgusted bite yeah
why did they go there in the first place
everywhere they go they never seem to
finish the job
and that's i'm pulling out what about
these legs that were lost
sad james matthews
sky news dal keith
well to the west the taliban remains an
extremist group whose history is
littered with executions assassinations
the subjugation of women
and the harbouring of international
terrorists that's the way it was in the
late 90s when they took control
i visited kabul at the time and
witnessed the repression
and the fear of ordinary afghans the
taliban says things have changed it
claims to be taking territory by consent
and has been involved in negotiations
over the future of the country but has
it altered its hardline stance has it
really changed
i spoke to the taliban negotiator and
spokesman suhail shaheen in doha and i
asked him
after recent military gains how much of
the country
it now controls in some districts
the kabul administration they initiate
offensive against us and we have to
react to their offensives yes there are
some
fighting but not in all districts
which have fallen to us now what the
world is worried about
is that uh the last time you were in
power in 1996
it began i was there in kabul and i saw
what you did
you imposed this harsh brand of sharia
law
and justice i saw your opponents hanging
from lamp posts you had public
executions will you be doing the same
again
you said about this lamp post in those
hanging our opponents yes i saw
i saw president najibullah hanging from
a lamppost you were
hanging your political opponents from
lampposts
yes that was a in a situation when the
couple see city was taken and after that
there were we had a government and there
was a system
of local courts judiciary there and
everyone had
the right of a defense right even now
we have judiciary system better
than that which is prevalent
in kabul administration okay now you
also
banned girls from going to school you
banned girls and women
from working you banned girls and women
from leaving home without a male
chaperone you banned them from showing
skin in public
you banned them from taking senior jobs
or going into politics and even speaking
publicly
if you take power will will you do the
same again
these are some of the stories of the
media these are
some of the points of propaganda you
just
repeated those propaganda of our
opponents
of our hostile
school but forces couldn't go to school
could they and now there are 3.3 million
girls at school
there are women in politics in law in
medicine there are journalists
women who are in business owners police
officers
are you telling them those women that
they will not be able to do that
in future if you're in control
i have not said that i what i'm saying
that women have right
to have access to education and to
work this we have said
in abraham conference
here in dauha and another counters
that we had in moscow right and last
time you harboured
osama bin laden protected him um
you harbored al-qaeda terrorists
um a u.n report says there are up to 500
al-qaeda fighters
in afghanistan now um
the fear is that you will allow
afghanistan to become another
launch pad for terrorism that is not
true
i do not agree with that
which bid is not true we have where all
these 5 000
in this launching part not true because
we have this agreement of doha agreement
we have commitment that we will not
allow anyone
or any entity to use the soil of
afghanistan against the united states
its allies in other countries right what
is the most
likely outcome for afghanistan is it a
negotiated political deal
um a full taliban takeover
or as many think another endless civil
war
i think it is a negotiated settlement
for afghanistan i see it
there should be negotiated settlement
for the country because only in that
case
we can have a durable peace it is our
policy
military approach will bring victory
but not a durable peace
that's a member of the uh taliban
leadership speaking to me earlier
well the war was fought not primarily to
remove the taliban from power but rather
to ensure that the country could not act
as a haven
for terror training camps and the
leaders of al-qaeda
but as us and uk forces withdraw the
former head of mi6 alex younger has
warned that it could well mean the
resurgence
of al-qaeda and an increased terror
threat
to the uk uh foreign affairs editor
deborah haynes is outside the
ministry of defense in london good
evening
deborah and do i detect a certain amount
of frustration
even anger on the british side about the
way this is
ending
well there's def there's no doubt that
the uk did not support the us decision
to call time on this conflict before
there was any
real semblance of stability on the
ground
but i thought the the comments from sir
alex younger were particularly
um interesting and significant his main
message was
that it would be an enormous mistake in
his words
for the west to turn their back on
afghanistan
in the way that they did back in 1989
and that year is significant because in
february of that year
it was when the then soviet union
withdrew its forces
from afghanistan the west turned its
back
the taliban rose to power and like you
were discussing with your
that taliban official just then the um
the the country was then a haven became
a haven
for al qaeda and when the uk and the u.s
went in there
they found an infrastructure to conduct
terrorism that they could never
have imagined before they went in and
that is the concern that
once again with true with forces
withdrawing
some kind of terrorist network could be
allowed to thrive and
let's listen to what sir alex said
specifically about that threat
the reality is that there are groups
there we've been very successful in
disrupting both
daesh and al-qaeda they're on the back
foot
but they i will be wrong patently
declaring that they have gone away
and they have the capacity to regenerate
if terrorist groups are allowed to
regenerate
somewhere like afghanistan it will be it
will lead to more threat
on the shores of our country and our
allies
we were told that the prime minister was
set to chair a national security council
meeting today
these meetings are held in in secrecy
we're not briefed about them beforehand
or or after so we don't know if it's
actually taken place
but i can tell you that when i was
walking down whitehall just now i did
see the defense secretary
coming out of the cabinet office
building i also saw
the national security adviser emerging
they wouldn't talk to me so i don't know
why they were there
so maybe that meeting has happened maybe
not but we did hear from ben wallace
earlier in the house of commons when he
also
raised concerns about the future threat
potentially coming from afghanistan
we will continue to work with the afghan
government
and we continue to focus on the threats
that emanate from afghanistan
and may grow to emanate towards the
united kingdom and our allies
and we will do whatever we can however
it is important in forward presence
that we are always in those countries at
the consent of
the countries there was a doha agreement
there was
another peace agreement
we do believe that some point this week
we're going to get clarity from the uk
government about their future footprint
in afghanistan we think that that will
involve the uk embassy potentially a
small number of regular troops
potentially special forces as well
though that will never be officially
confirmed okay deborah thank you very
much indeed
well when president george w bush
announced the u.s invasion of
afghanistan in october 2001 the aims he
set out were pretty clear disrupt
terrorist networks bring those
responsible for
terror acts to justice and cut the
military capability
of the taliban 20 years on osama bin
laden is dead and no major terror
attacks have been launched from
afghanistan against the west since
but as we've seen the taliban are very
far from being a spent force
our diplomatic editor dominic waghorn
has been looking at whether coalition
forces
leave afghanistan with in any sense
mission accomplished on my orders
the united states military has begun
strikes against
al qaeda terrorist training camps and
military installations of the taliban
regime in afghanistan
air strikes and a promise from a
president to use force with deliberate
purpose
these carefully targeted actions are
designed to disrupt the use of
afghanistan
as a terrorist base of operations
the allies military aims in afghanistan
were at first
clearly prescribed destroy al qaeda and
render the taliban
unable to help it the military action we
are taking
will be targeted against places we know
to be involved in the al-qaeda network
of terror
or against the military apparatus of the
taliban
but then the mission morphed expanding
into what sounded like
nation building we know that true peace
will only be achieved when we give the
afghan people the means to achieve
their own aspirations whatever that
meant the allies would spend another two
decades and two trillion dollars trying
to achieve it
john negroponte was u.s ambassador to
the un at the time
having clearly defined objectives at the
before you enter into a conflict i think
always carries
with it substantial risks but in terms
of what happened in afghanistan was it a
mistake
to take on nation building to expand
that mission outwards it certainly
it was a risky proposition
and uh you could call it a mistake
but it wasn't just mission creep a huge
distraction was coming
that would undo the chances of success
general sir robert fry commanded the
royal marines in afghanistan
i think there was an opportunity
fleeting and squandered but there was an
opportunity which
had it been properly um exploded could
have
perhaps have created a lasting solution
or if that was too much to hope
at least given the afghans themselves a
fighting chance to sort themselves out
the reason it went wrong was iraq of the
labour cabinet who voted for military
action in 2001
only one would talk about it now claire
short
unsparing in her assessment of the
west's achievement in the decades that
followed
it's a failure i mean it's it's a
terrible cost in human life
and masses of money spent that hasn't
brought a beneficial outcome for the
people of afghanistan
and it's a humiliation for nato i mean
it really is
the taliban beat nato
more than 450 british lives have been
lost in afghanistan
more than 2 000 american tens of
thousands of afghan civilians have died
the cost has been put at something over
two and a quarter trillion dollars
if as seems more than possible the
taliban can now sweep back to power
what was all that sacrifice for
afghan forces must rely on themselves
now and their training
the true test has yet to come if they
fail to hold back the taliban
the west's adventure in afghanistan is
doomed to spectacular
and costly failure dominic waghorn
sky news well i'm joined now by general
sir david richards now lord richards uh
the former chief of the defense staff
who also
led nato forces in southern afghanistan
and knows
all there is to know about this country
so sir david i mean international troops
have gone already the taliban
are marching across the north capturing
district after district and many afghan
troops i see are fleeing i mean how
would you describe the future for
afghanistan
well i think the there is a huge risk
that we will
soon have a proper civil war in
afghanistan
um some of our war aims have been
achieved
most notably that to do with terrorism
and its export
but that even will become vulnerable as
this develops and
ungoverned zones almost certainly uh
starts springing up
which we can't get at and which the rump
of the afghan government won't get her
so a pretty sorry tale of
uh british and western and american
the grand strategy gone badly wrong
that's right
so if that is the future then the west
may be seen to have failed where do you
think it
where do you think it did go wrong
well uh look let me just say first of
all it needn't yet
fail uh not entirely anyway bits i'm
afraid
uh will not have been achieved and
that'll be uh
to our shame really because of the moral
uh
factors that uh you know we're at the
heart of some of this and which we will
have
failed in and let down the afghan people
we made big promises to them
but actually i what i want to see now
and i'll quickly come back to your
question
it is a coherent plan that salvages
whatever can be salvaged from this
situation
and i don't think it's too late but what
i hear
is a a a a lot of sort of rather pious
uh wording uh what we need is a coherent
dynamic
well resourced financially
uh uh a rail resource plan that as
uh your excellent correspondent has said
combines
carrot and stick in in a way that will
still
persuade the taliban that they have to
conform to some
standards but could that have happened
you know 10 to 15 years ago were we
were we fighting a very expensive war
clearly in iraq was that the wrong war
and we should we have been concentrating
resources and focusing attention on
afghanistan
yes the americans took on too much
uh you know rather buoyed up by their
success in afghanistan
they turned their attention to iraq
realized they'd bitten off more than
they could chew
nato and that's when i went out to
command the nato expansion across the
country
uh in 2006 uh rather reluctantly agreed
to take on some of
the responsibilities from the americans
the americans then focused on iraq
and rather left afghanistan to nato
and i'm afraid nato and european nations
in particular just weren't up to the
challenge
either in terms of their financial
resource
or indeed the amount of military
activity they were prepared to put into
it i have to say the americans to be
fair when you went to america in that
period one felt they were
at war you know you saw soldiers uh
you know traveling free on aircraft and
you know
being sort of almost worshipped by the
population
in britain i never got that that
impression nor indeed obviously in the
rest of europe
we were sort of in in a conflict but we
weren't full-bloodedly
in afghanistan the way the americans
tried
but couldn't manage it's the americans
clearly intent on uh leaving now i mean
is there any sense in which the british
could you know stay on their own with
maybe other nato forces minus the
americans is that
remotely feasible well i don't think it
is because we haven't got the
stomach nor i fear now the capacity
to do it it's not actually a huge number
of troops
the americans were considering leaving
about three and a half thousand
uh combination of special forces but not
many
uh and then a run particularly of
air capability uh to ensure that the
afghan forces could continue to contain
uh the taliban
and preserve security in the key cities
uh
out of which we might slowly build
economically
in the way that was originally intended
um but you know
we talk a lot about defense cuts and
thinking about the future and
clever stuff that we're gonna get the
fact is
this is today's war and we don't we
can't really
manage it in the way that we should be
able to uh and
nor will other european nations step up
to the mark
so i'm afraid that moment if ever it
existed and certainly we could have done
10 15 years ago
if we wanted to i'm afraid that moment
is now gone
we depend on america okay uh general uh
sir david richards thanks very much
indeed
thank you well the war has cost
thousands of afghan lives
and many believe that it could develop
into a full-blown
civil war again once western forces have
completely pulled out
reconciliation may seem a distant dream
for many people there but
is a descent into uh renewed chaos
inevitable well earlier we heard from uh
fauzia kufi
a member of the afghan government's
peace negotiating team
it's almost the same yes things have
changed
we have a government institutions are
there um
you know there is a security
institutions money
progress on women's rights etc but if
you look at the whole situation in terms
of uh you know
still the risks for military extremism
is there
at the risk of institution once again
being
the victim of collapsing is there the
the risk for
you know losing some of these gains
are there i'm joined now by fakunda
nadiri a member of the afghanistan high
council
for national reconciliation and a senior
politician in
afghanistan um thank you for being with
us so
women's rights and women's role in
society
um have made some progress in the last
20 years do you fear that that
will all be wasted if the taliban
regain control
indeed if there is no guarantee and
there is no
assurance then
people talks about the reality of
experiences
and we already know that the experience
that we are talking about is not
only about 20 years ago but also about
these 20 years that we have been passing
through but um
that all brings us to the point to talk
about
this responsibilities
of this new chapter in afghanistan's you
know
a season the taliban spokesman i spoke
to
a little earlier in this program told me
that the rights of women and the rights
of girls would be
protected where they're granted by islam
he said
do you believe him do you believe them
do you have faith
in them
well you you see we all we're looking
forward to see positive changes
um on behalf of taliban's actions and
rulings uh uh we
we want to believe in actions not in the
words
right now even in the districts that
you already know that you know um
systematically is clutching
under the rule of taliban uh we are not
having
very um positive news from
women's rights in in those areas so
how can we trust further uh such kind of
um wordings i think this is very
important
that um you can ask taliban to show
such a kind of you know uh claims that
they make
in your studio uh in in the
districts of afghanistan right now that
they
some of them are under their control
right now
um in terms of the islamic
rights it has to have a very clear
notion of what they are talking about
because
it can have various interpretation and
we know
and it's unfortunate that taliban in
their previous
ruling in afghanistan uh applied the
most extreme interpretation of sharia
and not only 20 years ago they did this
but even today
or during this 20 years and right now
the districts that are that are under
their control
women's rights are not practiced in a
similar manner that they
usually practice that even a day before
that
the district was collapsed under the
taliban's ruling
fonda do you feel let down by the
americans and the international forces
deciding to leave now
let me let me clarify this fact as a
responsible citizen of this country and
as someone who
is working in the political field i have
to talk about the realities and i think
after 20 years
the withdrawal of nato and u.s troops
does make sense but uh i don't think
that i ha
i should allow myself to even have
issues with that
but our main concern is about the
the way that you withdrawal is taking
place we want to have a responsible
withdrawal from
international troops uh especially that
you know we have been thinking they have
been
building the country with us they have
been
working on different fields with afghans
from rebuilding our institutions to
women's rights to civil society
to the rule of law and
including yes
our only um
i'm ready to something so far
[ __ ] responsible okay
we're struggling with the connection but
you have made your point quite
forcefully thanks very much indeed
and we were talking about it there and
images of afghanistan are often
dominated by
uh well men with guns but daily life in
afghanistan is full of people
often women and young people who have
carved out a life for themselves
in spite of or perhaps in defiance of
the threat of violence against them
but the threat of a return of taliban
dominance would heighten
the risk for many finally in this hour
we return to our special correspondent
alex crawford who's been meeting
the women fearing life under the taliban
hospitals are filled with the wall
wounded many of them children
the latest here is a 13 year old girl
she's never known peace and there's been
a spike in casualties
since the international troops have
pulled out
many who worked alongside the us troops
are fleeing for their lives
fatima that's not her real name and her
children
have gone into hiding after death
threats from the taliban for her work
and empowering other women
i feel extremely abandoned i am i'm in
danger it's not only that i am in danger
now my kids are endangered
i was given rare access to film inside a
secret women's
refuge every woman and child in here has
run away or been rescued from abuse and
violence
and they're terrified of the return of
the taliban
their worst fear is that they will
disrespect them they will
use them abuse them or molest them or
whatever
and also they will kill them
here they don't believe the taliban
reassurances that they've changed
they tell me of forced marriages of
beatings and rapes where they have no
say
and that's what they fear the taliban
will enforce
this 21 year old told how she was being
forced to marry a 13 year old boy
i felt like my life was falling apart
she says until i got here
their fear of the taliban is real and
growing
as the group gets stronger and snatches
more territory
the young women of today's afghanistan
have had a glimpse of
free thinking and independence
and their martial arts training combine
the skills
necessary in this country how to survive
bomb blasts
and bullets all but one has been caught
up in terror incidents
many near their schools how scared are
you about going to school
i'm scared a lot whenever i leave my
house i'm scared
because we don't know if we'll come back
alive she says
18 year old katera gets emotional
telling us she won't give up trying to
be a lawyer
the explosions are normal to us now she
says
she's not afraid for herself but she's
terrified her family will
be killed have you lost anyone
my cousin and uncle died in an explosion
she says
almost everyone here has experienced
death
parts of afghanistan are unrecognizable
to taliban times
women owning and running their own
businesses like this cafe
but they fear they'll be amongst the
first to be banned by a taliban regime
i'm not feeling good because if
they come back to afghanistan so we will
have lost
all of these rights to go out
or even go out of home i don't like a
scarf
but i i can like she has to
wear her scarf if taliban come i i have
to wear a scarf
and it's awful for me
next door there's another business owned
and run by a woman
all this was taboo under the taliban
regime and many fear it won't be long
before those days are back again
the monuments to school children killed
in terror explosions
keep on increasing with few optimistic
about afghanistan's immediate future
and alex joins us once again from kabul
and alex you're there you're on the
ground what is the most likely way that
this unfolds in the coming months
i mean i think that is a pretty
impossible question for anyone to answer
right now because
there is so much uncertainty there's so
much insecurity but i tell you what
there are the ingredients for chaos all
the ingredients for
absolute anarchy there are a number of
different fighting groups
the taliban itself is exceedingly well
armed now
if you just take that one group in wada
province that we were with
they had a huge base i mean hundreds of
square kilometers stashed full of of
munitions
weapons mortars all brand new that all
the
sniper guns had been taken all the
military vehicles about 50 had been
taken
they are very very well armed they're
obviously proving to be
quite wily political manipulators as
well because they
are holding all the cards right now
they're in no mood
to negotiate and even though they're
talking piece
on the ground there appears to be no
evidence of
of actually wanting to collaborate with
the afghan government
or any of the other players and there's
a great
deal of uncertainty from all those other
people who
don't want a taliban regime there's a
huge displacement of people there are
the ingredients for a
humanitarian disaster there is
enormous uncertainty and as i say there
are many people who are actually
wanting to leave the country now there
are death threats against
female journalists there are death
threats against
female human rights defenders there are
death threats against interpreters and
other people who worked with
international troops
and there is a generally a feeling in
many ways although they didn't want
international troops to stay in the
country
they certainly didn't expect them to
abandon them like this
the future i'm afraid looks pretty dire
at the moment for those in afghanistan
okay uh alex thanks very much indeed and
uh
should be noted the taliban yet uh to
take any
of the major cities in afghanistan
well that's it uh that concludes our
special
program tonight the truth is war has
really been a way of life
in afghanistan for decades centuries
even the hope was that this time america
and britain and their allies
could change things for the better in
some ways
they have as we've been hearing but they
leave behind a country facing yet more
chaos
more uncertainty and more conflict
sky news tonight is coming next
you